Tại vì quyền sự biệt qua được đảo của năng tiền cá đậm chất biệt.
Năng tiền cá không đến từ những chuyện của phương cây mà tối từ chanh sân mai vài gấm và kiếc sân sản.
Đó chính là cách ai biệt quyền, Một Cosplayer, Prob, Micker và nhà sáng tạo nổi dung,
mang dấu ấn dân tộc vào thế giới hóa trang.
Dự án tiền cá viên Nam của cô không chỉ là một mang nhé phai đơn thần,
mà còn là sự biệt hóa oình chuyện của một năng tiền mang đậm bản sắc biệt.
Tạo hình nhân bật mang mò sắc chữ được, được phát triển từ nhiều chất liệu liệu sự,
lấy cảm ứng từ những tự nhiệt tình ta của hỏa sĩ phụ ngà.
Bộ trình sân mai bắt tiền ở đi lối hệ, cùng những chi tiết tình tề tối thử cơ đình chủ và bảo tăng.
Phục chăng mang hơi thử dân ra với hỏa tiếp khảm chai và kê sàng hỗ đặc trương,
tạo nên cuộc đối thoại đồng đau sữa chuyện thống và đường này.
Mỗi một chi tiết đều được cô chăm chút kiế lưỡng như một cái kể lại cô chuyện văn hóa,
đúng không bản chẻ thêm trên trọng gì sản biệt.
Bối hơn 25 năm nay người thử dõi và sáo về chiến trịu lượt yêu thích trên tiết tốc,
ID quyền, 2 còn được biết đến với nghệ dành ID có sự.
Hãy đã hầm định vị thế là một nhà sáng tạo lỗi dung mối bật với lối tiếp cận đậm chất cả nhân.
Ngoài ra, cô còn là tắc sả của SECOCE BLYDE i e-chồng mối mối bắt đầu và tương cộng tắc cũng rất nhiều nghệ sĩ lối biến trong các dự án hoa chàng lục đau.
Tại sự kiện Việt Nam Game Boss 2, 2,5% tối, cô sẽ cùng của đồng giọng thảo,
khiến kiểm và tương tình những tảy năng cosplay xuất sắp,
hứa hệ mang đến số ẩn đặc biệt cho cửa tiền.